Trascrizione: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Alzi la mano chi, di voi,
sa rispondere alla domanda:
"Che lavoro fai?".
Pochissimi: anch'io.
Io non so mai rispondere a questa domanda,
perché mi chiamano "quella che fa i video
di inglese su Instagram", o "La TikToker".
In realtà io sono una "content creator".
Chi di voi sa che lavoro è,
quello del content creator?
Molto bene.
Chiunque crei contenuti a scopo
di intrattenere, educare o informare
è un content creator.
I contenuti possono essere
di vario genere:
video, foto, articoli di un blog.
Infatti, la creator economy si compone
di una moltitudine di professioni diverse:
gli youtuber; i podcaster; gli influencer.
Tutti con l'obiettivo di creare contenuti
per la propria audience.
In molti tendono ad usare le parole
"influencer" e "content creator"
in maniera intercambiabile:
e in effetti, molte persone
sono sia uno che l'altro.
Anche se in realtà,
a distinguere queste due figure
c'è lo scopo per cui si producono
e si postano i contenuti.
È vero che un influencer
crea effettivamente contenuti,
come è vero che un content creator
può influenzare la sua audience:
ma lo scopo del content creator
è quello di creare
contenuti di alta qualità,
mentre quello degli influencer
è quello di allargare
la propria community,
e di sponsorizzare
prodotti o servizi di aziende.
"Creator Economy"
è il termine con cui si descrive
il modo in cui i content creator
si guadagnano da vivere.
I "content creator"
producono e postano contenuti,
coinvolgono l'audience
e trasformano l'attenzione in soldi,
e quindi monetizzano.
Un tempo erano solo i grandi media,
a creare e divulgare l'intrattenimento:
mentre oggi,
chiunque abbia un telefono
può creare contenuti,
e tramite internet farli arrivare
a un pubblico, a un'audience.
Stiamo assistendo alla decentralizzazione
dell'intrattenimento, della formazione
e dell'informazione.
Il settore della creator economy, ad oggi,
vale un miliardo e mezzo di euro:
e in Italia ci sono
più di 350.000 creator.
Ma è la crescita ad essere esponenziale,
con un più venti percento anno su anno.
Come mai questa crescita esponenziale?
Perché il 34% delle persone si fida
dei marchi con cui fa acquisti,
mentre il 64% si fida
più degli influencer che dei marchi.
Quindi, quando le aziende
collaborano con un influencer
prendono in prestito la fiducia
che la community ha verso questa persona;
e più fiducia uguale più acquisti.
Un "Content creator"
è come una vetrina che,
a differenza di una vetrina
di un negozio tradizionale,
che può essere vista solo dalle persone
che gli passano effettivamente davanti,
la vetrina del content creator
può essere vista
in qualunque posto del mondo
e in qualsiasi momento,
e quindi l'esposizione è esponenziale.
È per questo che sempre più aziende
sono disposte ad investire
in questa tipologia di pubblicità,
piuttosto di optare
per mezzi più tradizionali,
come tv e giornali.
Collaborare con le aziende
è solo uno dei modi
in cui i content creator
possono guadagnarsi da vivere.
Si può anche ricevere "revenue share",
ovvero una parte del guadagno
che le piattaforme come YouTube e Tik Tok
hanno dalle pubblicità.
Un altro modo potrebbe essere
quello di creare prodotti o servizi,
fisici o digitali,
e venderli alla propria audience.
Questo significa essere
un "imprenditore digitale":
e il 17% dei content creator
è effettivamente un imprenditore,
mentre il 39 percento
aspira a diventarlo in futuro.
Essere un imprenditore digitale
ti dà la possibilità di lavorare
quando vuoi e dove vuoi.
Piacerebbe a tutti, no?
Comunque abbiamo bisogno
di un senso di comunità,
come esseri umani:
e grazie alla tecnologia,
oggi possiamo trovare online
gruppi di persone che condividono
le nostre passioni.
Questi gruppi si chiamano community.
Le community sono create e gestite
da un content creator.
Le piattaforme diventano una casa,
e all'interno di queste community
si condivide e si impara
gli uni dagli altri.
Le community sono una casa digitale,
dove tutti sono i benvenuti
e a cui possiamo accedere
ogni volta che ci va,
da qualunque luogo del mondo.
Essendo nata nel '97,
quasi per tutta la mia vita
ho avuto accesso ad internet
e i content creator sono stati
parte fondamentale della mia istruzione.
YouTube, dico sempre, è un po'
la nuova biblioteca di Alessandria.
Si può imparare praticamente tutto gratis:
ed è per questo che, ad oggi,
la formazione online
creata dai content creator
può essere considerata un valido rivale
della formazione tradizionale,
soprattutto quando si parla
di Higher Education,
quindi università o corsi specializzanti.
Alcuni punti di forza
della formazione online
sono il fatto che è gratis o poco costosa,
perché appunto i content creator
hanno altri modi con cui guadagnano.
In più, i contenuti
sono sempre freschi e aggiornati.
In un mondo dove il cambiamento
è all'ordine del giorno,
è quasi obbligatorio rimanere aggiornati:
e i content creator lo fanno
in maniera eccezionale.
Dall'altra parte,
la formazione tradizionale
impiega mesi o anni
per aggiornare i programmi.
Ma forse, la cosa che più mi affascina
della formazione online
è il fatto che si può imparare
dai top di settore.
Senza muovervi di casa,
potete fare una lezione di cucina
con uno chef stellato,
oppure una lezione di recitazione
con una star di Hollywood.
Bene, ora che sapete esattamente
cosa vuol dire "Creator Economy",
magari qualcuno di voi
vorrà diventare un content creator,
e quindi voglio darvi qualche consiglio.
La prima cosa che dovrete fare
è trovare la vostra nicchia di mercato,
ovvero un gruppo di persone
che hanno gli stessi bisogni,
le stesse esigenze, le stesse passioni.
Per trovare la nicchia di mercato
perfetta per voi,
vi basterà fare una lista
delle vostre passioni,
delle vostre "skills" -
le vostre competenze -
e dei bisogni del mercato,
tenendo conto che i bisogni del mercato
devono in quel modo essere collegati
a una volontà delle persone di spendere.
E le persone sono disposte
a spendere i propri soldi
per tre sfere principali:
innanzitutto gli "schèi",
e quindi migliorare
la propria condizione economica;
migliorare le proprie relazioni,
che siano amicizie o amore;
e infine, per allungare la propria vita.
Bene: individuata
la vostra nicchia di mercato,
dovete iniziare a creare contenuti.
E i contenuti che ad oggi
vanno per la maggiore
sono gli "short form videos":
quindi video brevi,
dai sette secondi ai tre minuti.
Questo perché la "attention span"
sta diminuendo anno dopo anno.
"Attention span" vuol dire, appunto,
la capacità di concentrazione:
per quanti secondi riusciamo a mantenere
la concentrazione di seguito.
Calcolate che nel 2000 erano 12 secondi:
e oggi, solo 20 anni dopo, sono otto.
Chi, secondo voi,
ha una capacità di attenzione
migliore della nostra, oggi?
I pesci rossi.
Bene.
Un altro consiglio che voglio darvi,
quando create contenuti,
è farli il più "relatable" possibile,
quindi relatability.
Quello che dite, o quello che fate,
o il vostro percorso,
deve essere in un qual modo
collegato alla vostra audience:
devono rivedersi in voi.
Per esempio, io che insegno inglese online
non racconto solo delle cose belle,
ma racconto anche di tutte le figuracce,
o delle difficoltà
che ho avuto nel mio percorso.
Credeteci o no, in seconda superiore
sono stata rimandata in inglese,
quindi sono la prova vivente
che tutti possiamo farcela.
Forse, però, l'elemento fondamentale,
per avere successo come content creator -
ma non solo, anche nella vita - è la PP.
Non quella che si fa in bagno:
PP sta per Passion and Perseverance.
Passione e costanza
nel creare contenuti educativi
originali e facilmente fruibili.
Senza passione,
ti verrà difficile avere costanza.
Infatti, la Creator Economy
si chiama anche Passion Economy.
Come dicevo prima, i content creator
hanno avuto una parte fondamentale
nella mia istruzione,
e continuano ad oggi ad averla.
Quello che voglio, e il mio messaggio
di oggi per voi, è:
potete imparare qualsiasi cosa,
ogni giorno qualcosa di nuovo,
gratis, online.
Oppure, potete far diventare
la vostra passione il vostro lavoro,
che potete gestire tramite uno smartphone
da qualunque parte del mondo.
Oggi, grazie al web,
puoi trovare la tua casa
entrando a far parte di una community,
oppure creandone una.
Passion and Perseverance.
Grazie.
(Applausi)